.
Der Unkrautvernichtung Glyphosat
ist ein Thema,
dass sich viele gewünscht haben.
Denn es ist ein klassischer Fall von:
"Wem soll ich jetzt noch glauben?"
Ständig hört man völlig
widersprüchliche Dinge.
Und auch wenn man den Schlagzeilen
auf den Grund geht
und Artikel für Artikel
sorgfältig liest,
bleibt man ratlos zurück.
Denn wer Glyphosat wirklich verstehen
will, der muss wohl oder übel
in die Wissenschaft reinschauen.
Und zwar richtig ins Detail.
Nur wer hat schon Zeit für so etwas?
Richtig...
Wir.
Also Freunde der Sonne, holt euch
einen Tee, macht es euch gemütlich.
Wir steigen jetzt richtig durch.
*Titelmelodie*
Fangen wir vorne an.
Glyphosat ist ein
Unkrautvernichtungsmittel.
Und zwar das meistgenutzte der Welt.
Sprüht man es auf Pflanzen,
sterben die Pflanzen ab.
Das ist praktisch, wenn man z.B.
Bahnschienen billig und effektiv
von Bewuchs freihalten möchte.
Aber besonders praktisch
ist es für die Landwirtschaft.
90 % des weltweit
genutzten Glyphosats
wird in der Landwirtschaft
eingesetzt.
Man sprüht es z.B. auf die Äcker,
bevor man sät,
um vorab alle Unkräuter zu entfernen,
damit man Platz für das hat,
was man anbauen möchte.
Mehr Infos zu Glyphosat
und seiner Verwendung findet ihr
in unseren Show-Notes,
erster Link in der Videobeschreibung.
Was viele aufgrund der aktuellen
Berichte wundern wird,
einen Grund
für den Erfolg von Glyphosat
waren die guten Bewertungen
seiner Unschädlichkeit.
Die Wirkung von Glyphosat
beruht darauf,
dass es einem anderen Stoff ähnlich
sieht, dem Phosphoenolpyruvat.
Deswegen bindet es
in Pflanzen an ein Enzym,
das normalerweise
Phosphoenolpyruvat bindet.
Das Enzym wird so quasi verstopft und
kann nicht weiterarbeiten.
Dadurch kommt ein ganzer
Stoffwechselweg zum Erliegen,
der sogenannte Shikimatweg.
Für Pflanzen ist dieser
Stoffwechselweg lebenswichtig.
Wir Menschen hingegen
haben den gar nicht.
Deswegen ist Glyphosat für uns
verhältnismäßig unschädlich.
Aber natürlich
wird alles irgendwann giftig,
wenn man sich genug davon reinknallt.
Die Dosis macht das Gift.
Aber bei Glyphosat ist
diese Dosis eben ganz schön hoch.
Diese relative Unschädlichkeit wurde
von verschiedenen Behörden weltweit
auch immer wieder bestätigt.
Bis im Jahre 2015 die Internationale
Agentur für Krebsforschung, die IARC,
ihren Bericht zur Glyphosat vorlegte,
mit dem Urteil "wahrscheinlich
krebserregend für den Menschen".
Jetzt gibt es aber noch viele weitere
Behörden, die solche Sachen prüfen
und beurteilen.
Und Glyphosat wurde auch von
einigen anderen Behörden geprüft.
Die kamen alle zu dem Schluss, dass
Glyphosat nicht krebserregend sei.
Eine dieser Behörden war die EFSA,
die europäische Behörde
für Lebensmittelsicherheit,
die für die EU zuständig ist.
Bei diesem Bericht war das deutsche
Bundesinstitut für Risikobewertung,
BfR, federführend.
Wie kann das sein?
Wie es sein, dass die IARC scheinbar
zu einem völlig anderen Ergebnis
kommt als z.B. EFSA und BfR?
*Stöhnt*
Wenn man sich damit beschäftigt,
da fällt einem als erstes auf,
dass es
eine fucking Schlammschlacht ist.
Beiden Behörden wurde vorgeworfen,
beeinflusst bis bestochen
worden zu sein,
entweder von Glyphosat-Herstellern,
die mit Glyphosat viel verdienen,
oder von US-Anwaltskanzleien
auf der anderen Seite,
die die Hersteller
auf Billiardensummen verklagen.
Also ich habe einige falsche Anklagen
gesehen und eine Menge Spekulationen.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich nach diesem
Video ein paar böse Nachrichten
von beiden Seiten, weil ich mich
an den Spekulation nicht beteilige.
Aber das möchte ich auch gar nicht,
muss ich auch nicht,
denn die Gutachten beider Behörden
wurden ja wissenschaftlich begründet.
Nur damit das klar ist,
sowohl IARC als auch EFSA/BfR
sind seriöse wissenschaftlich
arbeitende Institute.
Schauen wir uns mal die Datenlage an.
Jetzt geht es rund.
Wenn wir herausfinden wollen,
ob etwas krebserregend ist,
dann gibt es leider nicht so
etwas wie ein Krebsmikroskop,
wo wir einfach eine Substanz drunter
legen können, anschauen
und dann sofort erkennen:
ja, total krebserregend.
Stattdessen müssen wir
ganz viele Puzzleteile sammeln,
um am Ende ein Gesamtbild
zu erhalten.
Ein wichtiges Puzzelteil
liefern Beobachtungsstudien,
auch genannt Epidemiologie.
Da gibt es
verschiedene Studiendesigns.
Bei Case Control Studie
nimmt man zwei Gruppen.
Einmal eine Case-Gruppe, das sind
z.B. Landwirte, die Krebs haben.
Und die vergleicht man
mit der Control-Gruppe.
Das sind dann z.B. Landwirte,
die keinen Krebs haben.
Aber in Alter, Lebensstil usw.
möglichst der ersten Gruppe gleichen.
Dann versucht man herauszufinden,
wie viel Glyphosat beide Gruppen
in ihrem Leben oder
den letzten Jahrzehnten abbekamen.
Solche Case-Control-Studien
haben folgendes Ergebnis:
Menschen mit einem speziellen Krebs,
dem sogenannten Non-Hodgkin Lymphome,
bekamen in ihrem Leben mehr Glyphosat
ab als die gesunde Vergleichsgruppe.
Diese Studien sprechen also
dafür, dass Glyphosat
die Krebsart
Non-Hodgkin Lymphome begünstigt.
Aber Case-Control-Studien haben
einen grundlegenden Schwachpunkt,
den kennen wir
auch schon von den Handys.
Den sogenannten Recall Bias.
Sagen wir, ich habe Krebs und werde
im Rahmen einer Case-Control-Studie
befragt, wie oft ich mein Handy
benutzt habe in den letzten Jahren.
Jetzt habe ich vielleicht
schon mal gehört,
dass Handystrahlung und Krebs
irgendwie zusammenhängt.
Das führt dazu, dass ich mich
viel stärker daran erinnere,
wie oft ich mein Handy benutzt habe
als jemand aus der Control-Gruppe.
Dasselbe gilt natürlich
auch für Glyphosat und Krebs.
Allein diese Erinnerungs-Bias
kann schon zu Unterschieden
zwischen den Gruppen führen.
Dann gibt es noch Kohorten Studien,
wo man Menschen über Jahre
oder Jahrzehnte hinweg beobachtet.
Kohorten-Studien sind aufwendiger.
Aber bei verhältnismäßig
häufig vorkommenden Krankheiten,
wie z.B. dem Non Hodgkin Lymphom,
sind sie deutlich aussagekräftiger
als Case-Control-Studien.
Eine solche Kohorte-Studie
ist die Agricultural Health Study.
Seit 1993 werden über 50.000
Landwirte aus North Carolina
und Iowa beobachtet.
Unter anderem geben sie an
wie viel Glyphosat sie benutzen.
In dieser Kohorten-Studie war bisher
kein statistisch signifikanter
Zusammenhang zu sehen
zwischen Glyphosat
und irgendeiner Krebsart.
Auch nicht Non-Hodgkin-Lymphome.
Allerdings war diese
Agricultural Health Study
zum Zeitpunkt der Bewertung
noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Und so sagten beide Behörden:
Nee, die Studie ist
noch nicht lange genug gelaufen.
Deswegen können wir einen
Zusammenhang zwischen Glyphosat
und Krebs zu diesem Zeitpunkt
noch nicht sicher ausschließen.
Die Studie läuft immer noch und es
gibt inzwischen neuere Ergebnisse,
die auch eher
auf Entwarnung hinweisen.
Die findet ihr auch
in unseren Show-Notes.
Also unterm Strich waren
die Beobachtungsstudien mit Menschen
zum Zeitpunkt der Bewertung schlicht
und einfach wenig aufschlussreich.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Wir müssen uns ein weiteres
Puzzleteil anschauen.
Bei den Tier- und Zellversuchen kommt
neben den eigentlichen Ergebnissen
noch eine weitere
interessante Frage ins Spiel:
Wer hat die Studien
eigentlich bezahlt?
Es gibt natürlich
unabhängige Studien,
die von unabhängigen Wissenschaftlern
an Unis oder Forschungsinstituten
durchgeführt werden.
Aber bei Glyphosat
gibt es auch einige Studien,
die von der Industrie
durchgeführt oder beauftragt wurden.
Da kann man sich natürlich denken:
Moment mal,
wie soll ich einer Studie glauben,
die von Glyphosat-Herstellern
finanziert wurde?
Andererseits muss
ein Mittel wie Glyphosat
natürlich erst mal zugelassen werden.
Und die Hersteller müssen
nun einmal selbst dafür sorgen,
dass alle notwendigen Tests
für diese Zulassung
durchgeführt werden.
Und das ist natürlich auch richtig.
So eine Forschung ist ja teuer.
Warum sollten hier
Steuergelder verwendet werden,
wenn irgendein Konzern
eine Zulassung beantragt.
Deswegen ist es in der Praxis so,dass
es einen Interessenskonflikt gibt,
deswegen muss man dem mit Kontrolle
und strengen Regeln begegnen.
Es gibt strenge Auflagen
zur Dokumentation, zur Durchführung,
um so etwas wie eine Fälschung
zu vermeiden.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Bewertung
gab es nur drei unabhängige Studien,
die untersuchten, ob Glyphosat
bei Nagetieren Krebs auslösen kann.
Zwei dieser drei Studien
wurden sowohl von der IARC
als auch von der EFSA
als zu schlecht aussortiert.
Zu diesen schlechten Studien
zählt auch die berüchtigte Studie
aus der Arbeitsgruppe von Seralini,
die leider bis heute als angeblicher
Beleg im Netz herumgeistert.
Die einzige unabhängige Studie,
die übrig blieb, war diese hier.
Sie fand keine Hinweise, dass
Glyphosat in Ratten Krebs auslöse.
Da waren sich
auch beide Behörden einig.
Nur eine Studie reicht natürlich
nicht, um eine Bewertung abzugeben.
Der Knackpunkt liegt also
innerhalb der restlichen Studien,
der industriefinanzierten Studien.
Ich sage das deshalb, denn
wenn man sich im Netz informiert,
bekommt man manchmal den Eindruck,
als würde sich die IARC
ausschließlich
unabhängige Studien anschauen,
die EFSA dafür Industriestudien.
Aber nein, ganz so einfach
ist es auch hier wieder nicht.
Es ist aber etwas Wahres dran.
Zulassungsbehörden schauen sich
alle verfügbaren Studien an.
Unabhängige sowie
industriefinanzierte.
Die IARC hingegen sagt, bei uns
läuft alles maximal transparent.
Deswegen benutzen wir
für unsere Bewertung nur Studien,
die öffentlich zugänglich sind.
Öffentlich zugänglich, dazu gehören
natürlich die unabhängigen Studien.
Die industriefinanzierten Studien
werden meistens nicht veröffentlicht,
weswegen sie vom IARC
nicht berücksichtigt werden.
Aber in manchen Fällen
sind diese Industriedaten
dann doch öffentlich zugänglich.
Nämlich dann, wenn irgendeine
andere unabhängige Behörde
diese Daten geprüft und in ihrem
Bericht ausreichend detailliert
wiedergibt und veröffentlicht.
In solchen Fällen berücksichtigt
die IARC also auch Industrie-
und Auftragsstudien.
Aber beide Behörden betrachten
insgesamt verschiedene Studien.
Bzw. die EFSA und das BfR
beziehen mehr
industriefinanzierte Studien mit ein.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein Grund
für die verschiedenen Bewertungen.
Aber auch das ist noch
nicht die ganze Antwort.
Wir müssen uns die Studienergebnisse
genauer anschauen.
Es gibt vier Langzeitstudien
mit Mäusen,
die im Zentrum der Bewertung stehen.
Bei diesen Studien wurde den Mäusen
1,5 bis 2 Jahre lang
Glyphosat ins Futter gemischt.
In diesen Studien gab es nun:
dass Glyphosat Krebs auslösen könnte.
Aber die Behörden
waren sich nicht einig darüber,
wie diese statistisch signifikanten
Ergebnisse zu deuten sind.
Das mag einige verwundern,
denn Statistik und Zahlen
müssten für sich sprechen,
würde man meinen.
Was gibt es dazu deuten?
Das wird schnell klar,
wenn wir verstehen, was statistische
Signifikanz genau bedeutet.
Sehr wichtige Lerneinheit!
Statistische Signifikanz
wird leider so oft falsch verstanden.
Theoretisch könnte ich
bei jedem Ergebnis
in der Wissenschaft behaupten,
war bestimmt nur Zufall.
Das kann man rein
erkenntnistheoretisch
nie mit absoluter Sicherheit
ausschließen.
Aber man kann
einen statistischen Test machen,
der berechnet, wie hoch
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist,
dass es nur Zufall war.
Vereinfacht gesagt.
Sagen wir, wir machen
eine Glyphosat-Maus-Studie.
Es kommt raus, die eine Mausgruppe,
die mit Glyphosat
hat ein bisschen mehr Krebs
als die andere ohne Glyphosat.
Dann müssen wir uns fragen,
wie wahrscheinlich ist es,
dass dieser Unterschied nur
eine zufällige Schwankung ist.
Je unwahrscheinlicher, desto
aussagekräftiger ist das Ergebnis.
Wir sprechen nun von einem
"statistisch signifikanten Ergebnis",
wenn diese Wahrscheinlichkeit
mindestens so klein ist
wie die Wahrscheinlichkeit mit einem
20-seitigen Würfel eine 1 zu würfeln.
Doch eins ist klar,
je öfter ich würfele,
desto höher
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass irgendwann eine 1 dabei ist.
Wenn ich bei einer Studie schaue,
unterscheiden sich die Nieren
oder die Lebern, dann schaue ich
mir einmal nur die Männchen an
und einmal nur die Weibchen und mache
jedes Mal einen statistischen Test.
Dann ist das so, als würde
ich jedes Mal erneut würfeln.
Anders gesagt,
wenn ich in vielen Studien
für viele Organe teste,
ob irgendeine bestimmte
Krebsart häufiger auftritt,
dann steigt mit jedem Test
die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass irgend eine zufällige Schwankung
statistisch signifikant wird.
Wichtige Take-Home-Message:
Ein statistisch signifikantes
Ergebnis ist nicht automatisch
so aussagekräftig wie es
der Ausdruck vermuten lässt.
Umso schwieriger ist es jetzt
für die Gutachter und Behörden.
Die müssen beurteilen, ob so ein
statistisch signifikantes Ergebnis
wirklich durch Glyphosat
verursacht wurde
oder ob es nicht doch
eine zufällige Schwankung ist,
die bei so vielen Tests
gar nicht überraschend wäre.
Schauen wir mal in die Ergebnisse
dieser vier Mausstudien.
Dann werdet ihr selbst sehen,
was ich damit meine.
Die vier verschiedenen Farbreihen
stehen für die vier Studien.
Ein Punkt ist jeweils
eine Gruppe von ca. 50 Mäusen.
Die X-Achse zeigt uns, welche
Glyphosat-Dosis sie im Futter hatten.
Die Y-Achse zeigt uns,
wie viel Prozent dieser Mäuse
einen Tumor hatten.
Sogenannte maligne Lymphome,
also Tumore der Lymphdrüse.
Erste wichtige Info,
keine der Glyphosat-Gruppen
unterscheidet sich statistisch
signifikant von der Kontrollgruppe
ohne Glyphosat.
Anders gesagt:
Die Abweichung von 0 Milligramm
Glyphosat ist nicht groß genug,
dass sie nicht
auch zufällig sein könnte.
Die zweite wichtige Info:
Für zwei dieser Studien
ist der Trend signifikant.
D. h., wir sehen hier
eine Dosis-Wirkungs-Beziehung.
D.h., der Kurvenverlauf
sieht irgendwie so aus.
Je mehr Glyphosat, desto mehr Krebs.
D.h., auch hier kann man
einen statistischen Test machen,
um herauszufinden,
wie wahrscheinlich es ist,
dass so ein Trend rein zufällig ist.
Wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit
klein genug ist,
sprechen wir
von einem "signifikanten Trend".
So einen "signifikanten Trend"
haben wir in dieser Studie hier.
Bis auf den Ausreißer sieht es so aus
wie eine Dosis-Wirkungs-Beziehung.
Allerdings gab die EFSA zu bedenken,
dass diese höchste Dosis
doch sehr hoch war.
Sie sagt, wenn
eine krebserregende Wirkung
nur dann bei einer akut
giftigen Dosis zu sehen ist,
kann das ein Grund dafür sein,
diese Substanz
nicht als krebserregend einzustufen.
Denn eine akut giftige Dosis
kann Zellen im Gewebe töten,
wodurch neue Zellen nachwachsen,
was zu Wucherungen führen kann,
was in Krebs ausarten kann.
Dieser Effekt tritt erst auf,
wenn ich in
einen stark giftigen Bereich komme.
Es gibt also einen Schwellenwert.
Wenn ich nicht drunter liege,
gibt es keine Krebsgefahr.
Und weil quasi alles giftig ist, wenn
ich nur eine gewisse Dosis erreiche,
gibt es kaum eine Substanz
auf der Welt,
bei der dieser Effekt
nicht auftreten würde.
Versteht ihr?
Anders ist das bei Substanzen,
die grundlegend krebserregend sind.
Wie z.B. DNA-schädigende Substanzen.
Wie Tabakrauch.
Die haben keinen Schwellenwert.
Wenn sie niedrig dosiert sind,
sind sie weniger krebserregend,
aber immer noch ein bisschen.
Deswegen sagt die EFSA
bei dieser Studie:
Es gibt zwar einen signifikanten
Trend, aber die Ergebnisse
deuten nicht darauf hin,
dass Glyphosat Krebs auslöst.
Anders ist es bei dieser Studie.
Die zeigt erstens einen richtig
schönen Dosis-Wirkungs-Verlauf.
Also je mehr Glyphosat,
desto mehr Mäuse hatten den Krebs.
Und das jetzt auch schon
bei viel niedrigeren Dosen.
Aber man sieht auch, diese Daten
passen nicht zu den anderen Studien.
Gäbe es einen echten Effekt, müsste
er dann nicht wenigstens ansatzweise
auch bei den anderen Studien
auftauchen?
Die EFSA schlussfolgert,
dass es sich hier
um einen zufälligen
Kurvenverlauf handeln muss.
Wenn man viermal mit einem
20-seitigen Würfel würfelt,
kann da eben auch mal
eine eins dabei sein.
Das waren nur zwei konkrete
Beispiele, um zu verstehen,
wie die EFSA "statistisch
signifikante Ergebnisse"
als nicht überzeugend einstufen kann.
Die IARC sah das anders.
Innerhalb der berücksichtigten
Studien gab es bei zwei Studien
für zwei unterschiedliche Krebsarten
jeweils ein erhöhtes Risiko
durch Glyphosat.
Woraus die IARC schloss, das sind
hinreichend gute Belege dafür,
das Glyphosat
Krebs in Mäusen auslöst.
Es wurden auch noch
weitere Studien begutachtet.
Z.B. ob Glyphosat eine
DNA-schädigende Wirkung hat.
Es gab dazu auch Hinweise, u.a.
in Mäusen, die aber auch erst wieder
bei extrem hohen Dosen auftauchten.
Die IARC schloss daraus,
ja, es gibt starke Belege
für eine DNA-schädigende Wirkung.
Die EFSA hingegen sagte, nein,
es liegt an der akut hohen Dosis.
Die ist für die DNA-Schäden
verantwortlich.
Deswegen das Gesamturteil,
nein, Glyphosat hat
keine DNA-schädigende Wirkung.
Jetzt wissen wir,
Zell- und Tierversuche haben nur eine
beschränkte Aussagekraft für Menschen
Wir erinnern uns, die
Beobachtungsstudien mit Menschen
waren nicht aufschlussreich.
Doch die verschiedenen Puzzleteile:
Zellversuche, Tierversuche,
Beobachtungsstudien
geben am Ende doch ein Gesamtbild.
Und hier sagt die IARC:
Wir sehen eine DNA-Schädigung, eine
krebserregende Wirkung bei Tieren.
Deswegen ist das, was wir in den
Case-Control-Studien beobachten
wahrscheinlich eine echte Erhöhung
des Krebsrisikos durch Glyphosat.
Die EFSA sagt:
Wir sehen keine
DNA-schädigende Wirkung
und keine krebserregende
Wirkung in Tieren.
Deswegen ist das, was wir
in den Case-Control-Studien sehen,
wahrscheinlich nur
auf Biases-Fehler zurückzuführen,
wie z.B. den Erinnerungsbias.
Was bei solchen Studien typisch ist.
Ein genauer Blick in die Forschung
zeigt uns Folgendes:
Dass die beiden Behörden zu
unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen kommen,
ist auf beiden Seiten
wissenschaftlich nachvollziehbar.
Und lässt uns wohl oder übel mit
einer gewissen Unsicherheit zurück.
Wobei man für Alltag
und Praxis schon sagen kann,
für die meisten Menschen gilt:
kein Grund zur Panik.
Vor allem wegen der ordentlichen
Grenzwerte, die wir haben
und der geringen Mengen, denen
wir tatsächlich ausgesetzt sind.
Siehe Show-Notes.
Bei aller Unsicherheit sollten
drei Sachen trotzdem klar sein.
Erstens: Wir brauchen mehr Studien.
Wir müssen die Gefahrenbewertung
immer wieder aktualisieren.
Zweitens:
Es geht hier nicht nur um uns und
Krebs, sondern auch um die Umwelt.
Eins muss uns auch klar sein:
Ackerbau an sich ist immer
ein massiver Eingriff in die Natur.
Ich meine, wir machen flächenweise
alle Pflanzen platt,
nur, um die Pflanzen anzubauen,
die wir essen können.
Das ist nie ein gesundes Ökosystem.
Und allein in dieser Hinsicht
ist es auch egal, ob wir die Pflanzen
mit Pestiziden entfernen, ob wir
pflügen, mit der Hand raussreißen
oder ob wir Flammenwerfer benutzen.
Zumindest die Insekten,
die Wildkräuter oder Blüten suchen,
werden so oder so keine mehr finden.
Ich will damit sagen, eine
bestimmte Unkrautvernichtungsart
einfach zu verbieten, macht die
Situation nicht automatisch besser.
Sinnvoller ist es, wenn wir viele
verschiedene Werkzeuge zur Hand haben
und dann auf Basis wissenschaftlicher
Kriterien beurteilen,
welches Konzept
wo welche Vorteile hat.
Drittens:
Es sollte klar sein,
diese Schwarzweißsicht,
mit der oft
auf das Thema geschaut wird,
ist aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
nicht gerechtfertigt.
Es ist weder
wissenschaftlich eindeutig belegt,
dass Glyphosat krebserregend ist,
noch ist es unwissenschaftlich, diese
Möglichkeit in Betracht zu ziehen.
Es ist also nicht immer nur
eine Frage der Zahlen und Fakten,
sondern immer auch eine Frage
der Interpretation.
Auch das ist Wissenschaft.
Natürlich hätte ich euch heute auch
lieber eine Antwort gegeben.
Aber wenn die Wissenschaft
das nun einmal nicht hergibt,
dann müssen wir lernen,
auch mit solchen Unsicherheiten
vernünftig umzugehen.
D. h., dass wir nicht
in Spekulationen verfallen,
sollen uns informieren, aufklären und
ansonsten abwarten und Tee trinken.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk
Cheers.
Okay, who am I kidding?
Mein Tee ist schon lange leer.